look at casey mize he's got great
numbers
uh 88 in the third inning so far
and 26 walks and 71 strikeouts that's a
pretty good ratio for a young pitcher
like casey meyers now osmani in his last
eight games has driven in 13 runs
right side past the dive of scope
tim's around third to come home and
yasmani drives in yet another run and
the sox continue their offensive bonanza
in the first inning in detroit just love
to see asmani picking on pitches in the
zone and taking advantage of it because
he was walking a lot this is a slider
that doesn't do a whole lot it kind of
sits there
and even though they're playing him to
pull he just shoots it by scope so tim
scores easily socks on top one to
nothing
one zip socks
the batter is brian goodwin they will
over shift to the right against him
goodwin slices this ball up the alleyway
and left center field and pass the reach
of badou to the wall that will help yaz
to come home goodwin on his way to third
and the sox lead two to nothing
into the sunlight with a slice job
for brian goodwin
we told you it's not easy to see the
ball in left and center field because of
the bright sunshine and both badou and
cameron had problems with this
picking on a 3-1 fastball down he drives
it in the alley badu misses it cameron
misses it and all of those misses
allowed yasmani to score all the way
from first base
it's a three base hit it's a run driven
in lancelin on for his 15th start he's
seven and three era just over two last
time out because of the rain he only
went three innings
so we look for him to have
a strong arm tonight question is how
deep can he carry it into the ball game
two-nothing socks but the tigers
threatening here
lynn has the sign he wants here's a
pitch swinging a missed strike three
on the cutter he's got two strikeouts on
that pitch the tigers leave two into
jake berger
first round draft pick of the sox
four years ago
and he ends up tearing his achilles not
once but twice the second time over the
course of his rehab from the first one
51 games in 2017 four of them in arizona
mostly with kannapolis
up the middle for berger to second base
and castro turns two it's four to three
on the double play
not every first at bat is a dream sequel
jose abreu struck out took a called
third his first time up two-nothing
socks were in the third inning another
0-2
he struck him out again
[Applause]
two times in a row looks like he quick
pitched him again here's yasmani grandal
who had that rbi single back in the
first
he went too far and casey mize strikes
out two in the third it's two nothing
chicago
anderson at shortstop shades up the
middle not a full shift though he's to
the left of second base
burger the third baseman deep and well
off the line
tigers again with runners at second and
third for the second time in this game
the o2 swinging to miss fastball up
hard of pitching my goodness
sixth strikeout for lancelin ends the
fourth for the second time in this game
the tiger strain runners at second and
third
then i asked him how it was to have his
first walk-off flint
there's a chopper in the hole
those those are rogers first to third
eaton's throw is cut off tiger has got
something brewing here in the fifth
then in first and third chance for the
tigers to get back in this game scope of
the drive
deep left field
vaughn
leaps and makes the catch rogers will
tag tigers are on the board thanks to
the sacrifice fly from jonathan scope
tying run on base well this part of the
order six seven and eight is over six
sinker up and in into left and through
vaughan
soaring through the night for route
number one that is an outstanding play
in an exhale from andrew
landrieu realized pretty quickly he
wasn't going to be able to run this down
without a dive and watch it again our
all-state good hands he comes across
knows he can make that catch but only
with a full out dive
two one
two out
and here is rogers who singled last time
rogers has seen 17 pitches in three at
bats tonight against lance lynn
this has been a battle for lance
full of moxie lance lynn
two and two pitch number 117 tonight
is strike three
lynn fired up had to work incredibly
hard to get through that sixth inning
but he'll walk off the field with a 2-1
lead after six a base hit would be jake
berger's first major league hit
[Applause]
center field
can't find it it's down
burger drops it into right field
and jake berger
on a ball that got lost in the lights
that cameron needed a compass for
burger has his first major league hit
in detroit on a ball that just
disappeared in the lights and he ends up
at second base by hustling to second
base he takes the double play out of the
equation for danny mendick
mendick high in the air right center
field
cameron's underneath to make the catch
vaughn tags from third and he scores
berger behind him to third base and the
sox make it a two-run lead again it's
three to one andrew vaughn will lead it
off
andrew vaughan lays into this one
deep left field bring him home 4-1
andrew vaughn's fourth straight game
with two hits
and the socks are up three
kevin sheets trying to lift him baseball
here
oh a high fast ball that is absolutely
hammered
home run number two for gavin sheets
a majestic three-run shot
he's one of the few left-handers around
that can get on top of high fastballs
there's not a whole lot of guys that can
do it